Great negotiators always try to create as much value as they can, economic and non - economic.
They try to claim a full share of that value...
...and do so in a way that works for the long term on a sustainable basis.
Creating claim value for the long term...
...really requires acting in what we sometimes call three dimensions.
The most familiar is tactics and good tactics.
Moving from positions to underlying interest, building trust, active listening.
We're familiar with these skills and they're critical.
A second dimension is deal design and that's the art and science...
...of unlocking value from situations.
Whether it's a simple buy - sell agreement, or a more complex trade...
...with contingencies and risk - sharing provisions that has to play out over time,...
...deal design is critical as well.
Less well understood and probably less well acknowledged,...
...except by truly great negotiators, is the importance of setup.
And these are the moves away from the table...
...that makes sure that you've got the right parties, dealing with the right issues...
...having built up the right no deal alternatives or walk away alternatives,...
...in some cases worsening notes of the other side,...
...and orchestrating the process in the most promising possible sequence.
All of those elements; parties, no deal options, sequence and process plan; are key.
Great negotiators act away from the table...
...so that they've got the most promising setup once they're in place.